get your phone calls here we start out
with Harry no location given by Mario so
Harry Harry once talked about the Cubs
hi Harry good morning what do you have
for me what a privilege well where you
been Harry
well my bed I'm in upstairs I've been
I've been convalescing so to speak well
congratulations on the Cubs I I didn't
know you were just upstairs I thought
you were like really really upstairs
how did you celebrate the Cubs making it
to the World Series dad I just want to
say back in 1991 I said it sure is God
made green apples someday the Cubs would
be in the World Series and guess what
they're in the World Series dad then
they have all the exciting stuff now I'm
pretty sure they're gonna go with sec
listen game blood I'm surprising your
game - you gotta go with the Rick Russo
he's a crafty crafty crafty pitcher and
not afraid of a little brunch since
they're retired Harry don't it's Richie
and he's retired - Harry do you have an
updated roster well we're glad to have
you they have old style up there on tap
they've got wonderful catering dan pick
a food name a food ribs I got it
name another food kielbasa and it's all
supervised by
downshift what's going process he's not
dead he's not no you're not no don't
don't come up here do you wish you were
calling the World Series they're here I
gotta tell ya I wish I was it'd be a
thrill of a lifetime I mean this
ballclub I had a little fun with you
David some of the 84 guys but this
ballclub is stat John here buyers Xavier
Anthony Rizzo I loved him in Greece but
I loved them even more as a cab and and
here's what's so remarkable you got this
guy Maddon how great has he been I mean
he won a a world championship in the NFL
with the Oakland Raiders the Dallas
coaching baseball they would've thought
that's just a character guy that's this
Joe Maddon ajaan coming back yeah he's
gonna maybe d-h starting tonight they
did not put a chicken bone in his no
that's not true
that's not true he did not get a chicken
bone but it looks like he's gonna die
age to night that's great how do you
think this series plays out though
Pete's Hall of Fame chances are dead but
he's not everyone gets a free GoPro and
women's GoPro sticks pretty Hardy we
just sit around and watch a lot of shaky
video of us jumping off of ledges and
what do you miss most about call
games I miss the excitement I don't see
the atmosphere new friends and of course
a tall cool Budweiser beechwood aged but
you didn't you drank during games these
announcers like Jill buck doesn't drink
during a game that explains a lot with
Joe Buck you knew his dad you knew his
dad Jack is dead and we're roommates we
have a good time watch a lot of movies
together watch a lot of nature
documentary khandha do you want me to
tell you how it ends
well Harry it's it's awesome to talk to
you I hope you stay in touch and I'll
let one call and you used it on us well
thank you Harry and go Cubs Thank You
Harry nothing wow that was surprise
guest the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience